votre pensée repose comme toute pensée
de droite sur la peur et son idée de
décadence
je voudrais parler d'Alain de moi après
tout la nouvelle droite c'est plus ou
moins identifié à son nom voilà un
bonhomme qui met des bouquins d'idées
sur non je n'ai pas qu'il n'y a que vous
voilà quelqu'un qui met des idées sur la
table discutons-les et sachons en quoi
elle consiste plutôt que je dirais de
s'envoyer des annettes
d'abord je note une chose dans ce
dernier livre qui m'a fait plaisir
[Musique]
Alain Benoît prudemment laisse tomber
tout le biologisme toutes les métaphores
par rap pseudo-scientifiques dont il
s'embarrassait un peu avant ce qui
d'ailleurs peut embarrasser un peu les
jeunes chefs du Club de l'Horloge
attendez je dis pas vous dites fort bien
vous dites fort bien et fort prudemment
qu'on a insisté là-dessus que ce n'est
pas le vrai débat et en effet nous
pourrons revenir sur ce faux débat ou
ses fausses idées tout à l'heure mais
vous avez bien raison de dire que je
crois que vous avez vous touchez des
points essentiels en disant moi je ne
parle pas fondamentalement de ça je
parle culture politique société alors je
voudrais parler de ça avec vous
je dirais d'abord que il y a dans votre
point de départ
quelque chose que je prends tout à fait
au sérieux et qui n'est d'ailleurs je
dirais ni de droite ni de gauche
je veux dire que vous êtes quelqu'un
comme la plupart d'entre nous qui
réfléchissait dans une société dans une
culture où il n'y a plus des garants
absolues les dieux la nature l'histoire
les droits de l'homme tous ces absolus
ça n'existe pas ça n'existe plus
pourquoi parce que nous qui avons été
les dominateurs du monde nous ne le
sommes plus il n'y a plus la Pax
Americana la Kennedy il n'y a plus la
Révolution française exportant ses
principes et ses armes avec Napoléon et
nous sommes dans du relatif et nous
sommes aussi environnés de gens d'état
de nations de groupe qui disent moi je
suis cheat moi je suis ceci moi je suis
cela des comédies des Kadhafi et vous
dites pourquoi pas moi
je veux dire pourquoi est-ce que nous on
serait les seuls à faire les ballots à
parler d'universalisme alors que tous
les gens défendent leur spécificité
et je dis quand je le pense profondément
ce sera une grande erreur de croire que
à l'un de Benoît et quelques autres
présentes une des gens égarés je dis
qu'il y a beaucoup plus de gens qu'on ne
pense
je veux dire que le monde est plein de
gens qui vous parlent d'identité de
spécificités de communauté à gauche à
l'extrême gauche partout et que s'il
s'écoutait parler il s'apercevrait
souvent que la nouvelle droite elle est
beaucoup plus répandue qu'on ne le croit
alors la question que je posais celle-ci
et c'est là qu'on atteint je crois les
problèmes sérieux nous sommes tous dans
du relatif nous sommes tous des gens qui
pensent que l'histoire que les hommes la
font et que comme vous le dites l'homme
est un être historique et sûrement pas
biologique bien
alors voilà où maintenant passe la ligne
car elle existe entre la droite et la
gauche et c'est pas des problèmes de
culture
c'est que vous vous dites et vous et
vous voulez vous voulez nous faire un
monde qui est un monde du mois un monde
du nous fermer s'opposant à d'autres un
monde de secte un monde de guerre un
monde d'exclusion tandis que la gauche
vous dit nous sommes pour la diversité
nous sommes pour la complexité nous
sommes pour la pluralité
dedans je ne suis pas pour mon essence
indo-européenne je suis pour que les
conflits que les débats que les
discussions sociales se fassent je suis
pour que la multiplicité des tendances
et des idées s'expriment tandis que vous
au nom d'un appel à la différence ou
relatif qu'au départ Jacques accepte
vous nous enfermez dans un monde qui est
quoi qui est le monde du 1 le monde de
l'ordre le monde de l'État et votre
problème c'est que comme autant de
Spengler qui a eu une descendance
fois contestable vous êtes quelqu'un qui
nous dites c'est Occident minoritaire a
peur votre pensée repose comme toute
pensée de droite sur la peur et solidité
de décadence et vous dites nous sommes
minoritaires mais nous nous sentirons
parce que nous sommes les meilleurs
écartons tout ce qui nous affaiblit
soyons forts soyons durs plus de femmes
plus de d'écologie plus de de gens mous
soyons durs le crâne rasé à la
montherlan et en avant pour défendre
l'Occident qui est devenu minoritaire
dans un monde de nationalisme déchaîné
et préciser ma pensée vous donner
l'occasion de préciser la vôtre
évidemment
personne ne peut s'empêcher de se poser
la question quel rapport entre tout ça
et ce qui s'est passé initié
et ce que je pense et ceci
c'est que ce qui s'est passé dans les
années 30 est venu d'une crise
économique et c'est donc sur le plan
économique que 1 mouvement qui s'est
même appelé national socialiste c'est
formé et ce à quoi vous réagissez c'est
pas ça et en ce sens là évitant les
parallélisme car la crise qui vous
touche ce n'est pas une crise de
l'économie c'est une crise de l'état de
l'État et de la culture si vous voulez
mais au sens de de la réalité de la
force de la puissance d'être collectif
de ce monde occidental c'est pourquoi
c'est sur le plan de la culture plus que
sur le plan de l'économie que vous
mobilisez mais vous jouez dans le monde
aujourd'hui je dirais plutôt le monde
d'aujourd'hui pourrait vous faire jouer
le même rôle qu'il a fait jouer à
d'autres à partir des années 30
[Musique]